all right
thank you
just waiting for the live stream link
and we'll be we'll be away
okay well
just to welcome to you all
um this is uh one of our many workshops
that we've got leading into the
long-term plan
um and council at the beginning of the
term made a commitment that we would
live stream these to give a greater
level of transparency around some of our
decision making while today is not a
decision-making Workshop it's just a
fleshing out of ideas that through
durian and some of the other teams one
of the important things that we had
around that was it's important for
councils to be engaged that process
really difficult if we don't have that
engagement and encounter subsequently
come along at a later stage and say well
actually I don't agree to that after the
stuff already done the work so the floor
is rhiannons for the day
and uh she'll call the shots as we go so
try to keep to the schedule which has us
finishing about 1 30. a little bit
earlier would be great as well
um so welcome to the public we're also
watching in
and hope they enjoy the uh the
discussions that we have
Rihanna it's all yours thank you mayor
oh sorry I forgot to admit uh Rhiannon
was going to say something about some of
the uh spreadsheets you have
um councilor just to let you know that
you've got copies of some of the maps
that are in the PowerPoint later on just
so that you can see
clear more clearly some of those Maps so
that's what they're for they will all be
on the screen so it's just
so that you've got larger print there
thank you okay so today's Workshop
um is focused for the long-term plan on
community well-being
um so this Builds on some of the
conversations that you as the council
had earlier in the process at the end of
last year and the things that you wanted
to focus on for this long-term plan so
we're going to start with a brief
presentation that will go on over some
facts about our community that's really
just context and then really focused on
seeking direction from Council in two
areas and so one of the things that you
indicated was important when you set the
um or confirmed the community outcomes
was that the whole community community
no matter where they live in the
district can expect a good level of
service so we've got some discussion
points for you around extension for
services which are not received in some
areas of the city so that's primarily in
the area of waste and curbside
collection and in the area of Road
sailing as well as an update on the CCTV
project so these are all projects that
are investment projects that would have
an impact on community well-being in one
way or another and the various teams are
here to talk to you about those and then
in the area of Community Development
having heard some of the facts about the
community and with all your knowledge as
counselors and many funeral
Representatives what what do you believe
is most important for the years coming
up as we focus on Community Development
so the outcomes from this Workshop will
come back in a report to council at the
end of the month
they will input where relevant into
asset and activity plans and we'll work
up any in consultation and engagement
requirements
that's just a summary of that of those
topics that I've just um spoken about
so before we kick in just a reminder of
the four well-beings that are part of
the local government act so Community
well-being means something quite
specific in the context of local
government it refers to social
well-being environmental well-being
cultural well-being and economic
well-being so council at the end of last
year when it was looking at what is its
vision and Community outcomes for the
city uh has come up with four outcomes
that reflect those well-beings so most
of the presentation today will be
focused on the area of social well-being
and what do you want to achieve in that
area although we'll also touch when we
talk about CCTV on that area of safety
as well
foreign so the relevant strategic
priorities and Community outcomes are
just listed there primarily for those
that may be watching the live stream
council's got strategic priorities which
include meeting the changing needs of
arangatahi our young people as part of
our wider population which is growing
older and more diverse and maintaining
Community affordability in a time of
economic liability and the community
outcomes one Community our youth older
people different neighborhoods and
communities basic needs are met and they
feel valued and proud to live here as
well as a vibrant safe study center
which meets our people's diverse
cultural needs
so my colleague um Danielle who is a
brand new member of the team and we're
really happy to have her on board
working with and supporting Community
groups and individuals who want to
achieve cool things it's just going to
help me
um with this presentation we've got a
few slides for you
um just with some information that
infametrics has pulled together for
Beyond 2025 as well as some other useful
Snippets just a bit of context about the
people who live in the district
yeah cool so let's say uh nerves make
you happy so I won't be going to the
doctor for a while but uh the tear grape
is just explained to us about our
community we bet and we're looking at
the aging groups here so what we can see
along the top those last three that
covert has really created a drop off in
our growth and we've said very
consistent but what we have seen change
is that our younger populace has gotten
smaller and our class 65 populace has
increased so we're seeing their change
in weight within the demographic
and then as we move into about our
community we've kind of got some
standout diversity statistics in here so
what we've found is that 17 of the
residents in invercargill are Maori
which actually puts us at the largest
Pacifica on the south island so we have
quite a large Maori populace down here
in invercargill we've also found that 20
of central invercargill is made up of
Aging populace which is putting towards
those diversity statistics there so we
can see two quite clear emerging groups
um what we can see though overall is
that lovely grave is a European group so
that is still holding the majority there
in all of our sectors but in front of
you is that map all of you should have
it and it does break down for the
ethernet groups within each suburb into
quite as
small and wiggle
thanks Danielle so yeah that chart
really just shows that the suburb level
where people live within the city and as
Danielle says there's a few sort of
standout misters that you might want to
take from that including that doubling
of the population of Asian descent who
particularly live in the Central City
area and you can see the areas in the
city that people are Maori and other
ethnicities as well as European
ethnicity live and then obviously we've
also just got
um
a note there about the fact that
invercargill does
um become home to Refugee populations so
far we've had people from Colombia and
from the Democratic Republic of Congo
um who have joined the invercargill
population over the last few years
chair I think there's a question
yeah rangi well look just about the
Asian demographics is Asian too broad I
mean when you look at Asia it's a
reasonably large place and obviously
we've got you know Vietnamese we've got
Chinese we've got Japanese we've got uh
like you know I've just about named them
all do we need to be more specific or is
just Asian is that good enough so this
is NZ stat sensor starter from the most
recent sensor so obviously everyone will
have filled their sensors out last week
but we don't have that data yet so the
way that Census Data works is at that
high level obviously Asia is an
absolutely huge place but they can't
provide breakdown of data a lower level
without
um causing privacy issues so that's the
information that we have obviously
within different ages
you know Origins you have different
cultural requirements absolutely
absolutely this is very broad brush does
that include the subcontinent yes
Evelyn I think sorry the chair isn't
here but I just noticed that um Rhiannon
just in terms of
the known lack of credibility you know
that's not quite the right word
um reliability of last census and some
of this data have we got any reason to
question
um how accurate or inaccurate it might
be for invercargill City because I am
aware that in other venues that I've
been at that some of the
um the outfall of last census is is
proving um
contestable
certainly there were limitations which
and I start to have have explained for
the census I'm not aware of any specific
issues that are different for
invercargill and I think the census NZ
stats rather are certainly working on
improving data for the next census but
that information is not yet available so
absolutely there are limitations with
this data set but we don't have any any
indications of specific issues for the
district
and following on from that given that
many of the those that had identified as
part of the Asian population have come
via sit
how
every any information from then about
how much debt has
altered in the post-covered era or the
during covert immediately post covert
um certainly sit numbers have were lower
over the covert period I haven't seen
any recent information for this student
intake yet but they certainly were lower
for the last previous two years
yep thank you
just one question
um
how's our Pacific island whanau sitting
population given that we have an
increase in Maori and Pacific
that's a really good question I'll have
to take that one away it wasn't drawn
out in the Thematic of this Infamous
report but certainly take that question
away and look into it
so just two questions for me um one is
the issue of the last sentence that was
that was done would sit students that
are on a one-year Visa be included in
those steps do you know census includes
everybody resident at the on the night
so not normally resident but anybody who
is in the country on that very stupid
it's not by sorry to be clearer it is
not by your status of your Visa or
anything like that
so yes it would have captured every
question of the chances are that the
Asian Community which in some courses
make up 80 to 90 of sit students on some
courses
um my world dropped off
certainly sit data itself over the last
few years over the time of covert
lockdowns was slower yes okay and the
other issue I think which Pioneer race
is the issue of Pacifica we tend to
Cluster them all together like the
question on the agents as well in fact
they're quite distinct communities as
well certainly the Samoan being the
largest
um so if we get some dart on that that
would be quite helpful and subtitude
so you've also got some of these
pictures
um in front of you which is
um a picture of
house
a home ownership and average rental
costs so there's a separate workshop on
the topic of housing next month so we're
not going to get into this into a huge
amount of detail but I think it's worth
noting that the average house price
only a few years ago was 3.8 times the
average salary and it's now 5.5 times as
of last year
um
and you can see from those pictures
different rental and Home Ownership
patterns within the city
so this chart here is a chart which is
produced by the University of Auckland
and it's called the index of multiple
deprivation and for all communities
within New Zealand they map different
statistical indices and compare which
communities experience switch issues so
this is the picture for invercargill
City and in a moment I'll flick and show
you the picture for love
one is the least deprived and 10 is the
most deprived we are as a community
sitting in that mid-range primarily
um some of the issues that we have
um less deprivation of crime and housing
for example
um where some issues where we have more
deprivation is education and health
outcomes where the city is is usually
scoring lower than the average within
New Zealand but we are sitting right on
that average five for the whole um
country so that gives you a kind of
picture of where invercargill sits let
me ask him Ryan and that that's
obviously a comparative number isn't it
they're not absolutes because there's no
definition of what those means I presume
they're comparative
um do you actually have a chart of New
Zealand as a whole I don't have the
chart finished yeah but is that the
comparator so is New Zealand represent
five there's something on that that's my
understanding I'll have to look into
that in more detail yeah because it's
absolutely meaningless because the
numbers don't actually mean anything
unless there's some definition with them
that's what I was I was really trying to
say
so if we score three it's three relative
to what would a three mean you know so
I'm assuming it's there must be some
chart that shows New Zealand to the
whole we may be things normalized to
five for New Zealand as well that might
be the case
so
I can certainly look out and share all
of the specifics behind this for how the
University of Auckland calculates this
it is just one way of looking at the
community however it is
um
it is well used across New Zealand and
it is felt to be a robust way of
measuring something that is all social
indicators are by their nature less hard
science than the hard sciences that is
the nature of these things are very
complex issues they're very difficult to
measure but this indices is one of the
most widely used indices in the country
um but I will certainly share the
methodology that sits behind it I can't
answer specifics around it right now
thank you okay so just adding to that um
in my involvement with the government
sector in particular who often funder
fun work towards deprivation and you
look at that slide that we've got there
you'd expect the government sector not
to be putting too much into crime or
into the quality of our housing as
opposed to the quantity but they may put
work into education outcomes and our
health outcomes at the moment which are
not as good as they would be if we were
sitting underneath as an example so they
tend to use these generic things that
you're right quite right Tom that
overlay what the average is in New
Zealand and when we slide below that
that's where we get detention when we
sit above we get we get little in that
portfolio because these relate to
government silos here rangi
I find the education outcome actually
insulting up there I would imagine that
an education outcome is that you leave
school and you they perceive if you
don't get tertiary education you you
know it's not a success whereas
basically when you leave school and you
get a job I'd say your education has
been reasonably successful and you're
happily employed now
there is no Thomas absolutely right that
there's a couple of there there
absolutely meaningless and uh they're
really I don't know how they use them
they must have been on some good stuff
and they come out with this one and
again I think the education one at the
moment if you look at what they're
focusing on tends to focus on attendance
right
and actual results while they're at
school so you you've heard the
discussion well Teresa CX been on this
heard the discussion around mass and and
some reading criteria as well to tell
you the current attendant rates and
invercargill as I did last week was 80
percent or below which is way ahead of
what the government's goal is but not
good enough
[Music]
yep great yeah just on that education
outcomes is it measuring Secondary
School outcomes or tertiary outcomes
what what what measure is it it's a
it can have much higher rates than the
national average of people with no
qualifications at all and then we have
lower rates of higher level
qualifications as well so it matches
everything from nce all the way up so
it's a combined indices and what what
um yeah
I suppose that can be skewed because
there could be older people that didn't
have any treasury you know
qualifications but subsequently there's
a lot of younger people that have got
significant education qualifications
so the relativity of that data needs to
be understood I would have thought yeah
yeah so I think
all the questions
that you're already
and what it
this is just one way of looking at an
issue and all these issues are hugely
complex so certainly don't take this
presentation that I'm trying to provide
as the be-all and end-all about the
community we all live here and know all
the facets of the community and all the
detail I think councilor poringer raised
a very good point around education
levels being relevant to the economy
that you work in we have a very good
level of employment for example and
there's a good match of skills all I'm
sharing is the information that is
available and that we can can use yeah
but I think the point of this Workshop
is to help us understand not only a
current situation but what's their
future need and then how do we
contribute to that future need as part
of a solution where central government
and agencies like severe funders and
those sorts of things so understanding
the data in very good detail things
comparative
and you're quite right grant I mean one
of the issues that we've looked at in
recent times if not the quantity of
housing uh the quality but the quantity
of Housing and we've looked to uh things
like lesbian others and career have done
the health portfolio as well which we uh
currently know are areas that we need to
up our game in as a community and what
can we do to help others to get that
that level up yeah
so this next chart and obviously with
all the provisos that we've already
discussed for invercar well this shows
for the bluff Community what the
um picture is so
um
you can see there's a lower level of
deprivation and issues like crime and
housing but a much higher level of
deprivation in terms of access to
services so that's reflective of a
smaller Community where people might not
have on their doorstep what they really
need and you can see they're the
education outcomes is slightly worse but
interestingly Health outcomes is is
a better outcome that's listed there so
again just a snapshot and a one way of
looking at the community
can you just go back to the access to
services in Bluff I think we need to
acknowledge
that one of the issues is the lack of
public transport yeah
um the fact that people have to come to
town to do almost everything except the
most basic of shopping and to go to the
doctor but all the rest of the services
are provided within the city but we do
not provide people who do not have
vehicles a means of addressing that and
I think that
this is something that I feel very
strongly about and I'd be surprised if
if Tammy and Tanya didn't feel strongly
about it as well because it's the reason
why some of us choose not to live there
to be really honest
so Rihanna I guess one of the issues
that would flow from a discussion like
that is you know we have free bus
services or nearly free buses running
around the city but we don't have them
to Bluff and if they're part of the city
that begs the question especially with a
rating on there that has a very poor
rating for Bluff on the access to
services and I guess against the uh
common perception of philosophy quite
low in crime which is
would be an eye out there to some people
maybe they just sort their own stuff out
yes yes yes I'll write about that yes
you can knock on the door at late at
night
um yeah so that that raises I think some
good information for us to be
considering that issue about the
transport as well because that'll be key
to the excess dessert I'm sorry sorry we
could bring back the price of train yeah
good luck with that they can tell some
stories yeah
so um one of the questions for you later
in this Workshop is are there other
services that you want to consider
extending so I I've noted down
discussion of public transport for that
point
okay so then um just a couple of more
pages of information so this shows the
crime deprivation specifically by suburb
um
where one and two are the lowest eight
and nine are the highest so you can see
where the known information
about chromos versus overall deprivation
so your black and white chart is the
overall decoration and the colored chart
to the side as the crime deprivation
statistics
so just to run that again for you yeah
the the darker the colors the more the
crime is that what you're saying yes in
that right hand side yep
and I think that would that would be oh
yeah I think that would be interesting
to some some elected members that often
we have a perception the further you go
south the more the deprivation around
crime but that's clearly not the case
Peter yeah
I'm sorry Peter uh why doesn't it
include uh
um lawnville macarawa Morris bush area
Killington prototype that's part of
invercargill
um so if you look to the top left hand
corner where it says invercargill City
other that is the all of the rest of the
district is packaged as one suburb and
that's based on the way NZ stats does
the division
yeah so that's the figure for the rest
of the city thank you and in terms of
the specifics of where the data comes
from I'll certainly look that out and
send it on
I mean intuitively it looks right
doesn't look but when you start to put
numbers against it you know you've got
to ask a question where does the data
come from and how confident are we about
the I mean intuitively it looks a bit
right
it is National stats data yeah it does
but then you know the perception would
be that you wouldn't expect Clifton and
certain Kings will to be actually raging
very well
okay
being mindful of the darker the color on
the right hand side
the higher the deprivation and crime
the other thing to do there will be
overlay it was perhaps data from police
and then also um you know the
understanding the nature of that
activity
um
[Music]
and that might help us with you know our
CCTV type stuff
yeah treasure could you clarify it
please for deprivation by crime do you
mean
that there was less crime or more crime
the way I I read Rihanna's response was
the lighter the color
um the the less the lower the crime I
guess is that levels yeah so it's a
combined indices made up of chrome
victimization statistics and crime
reporting statistics so the lighter is
the least lighter is less yeah okay
we're in some way some of our
deprivation actually goes the other way
yeah
um for you so just um through what Grant
just touched on is this sort of data
collection and maybe come looking at the
place dump States as well is this a sort
of
um momentum that would
um
appeal to where some of the CCTV cameras
are going good could very well be
because if we're looking at data and
we're
looking at how we can actually rate it
with the police National Data as well I
think that would be pretty
straightforward in the decision making
with a few different allowances
so I guess one of the issues we'll face
is is not just a matter of where the
crime is but how do we interact with it
so CCTV is one option it might be that
we provide a greater level of uh
facilities
um in an area that's got higher crime
statistics and deprivation so before
arguments like you know would we put a
pump track down in South City that might
help
um curb some of the
Teenage Crime I guess or nuisance crime
and it depends what the police are
counting as well because the biggest
growth in crime seems to be around
domestic violence which they now record
and react to very quickly we're either
back five years ago that was not the
case
um very yeah
um I see in the on there that the
Applebee area is uh seven
um you can't go
through an intersection an invercargill
in uh Apple Bay Area without seeing
multiple skid marks everywhere
there's none on a nice struck two of
them this morning at my house
what are you yeah what do you what do
you do with these people
including my very quiet side streets so
it's I don't feel picked on I it seems
interesting to me that
the highest
um
level of crime deprivation is actually
in an area
where there's a lot of businesses but
there's also a lot of retail alcohol
facilities and things like that I'm not
saying that we shouldn't have alcohol
please understand me but we need to
understand what are some of the other
drivers of these things and it's not
just purely
where people live or how well off they
are it's also where they go to recreate
and what sort of recreation they're
doing and when they do it so I mean it
might be really safe during the day and
less safe at night or things like that
and we need to understand that I think
okay
I think it's worth noting also that
um the invercargill central area for the
crime deprivation
um map also has higher density housing
so you've got a greater number of people
living closer together as well
I think sorry it's really good yeah
I mean I think as we look at those two
charts you know clearly there's uh
direct link between social deprivation
and you know what's called crime
deprivation up there in it and I think
that where we talk about CCT when we
talk about crane prevention and how you
know traffic police and so forth you
know it's what actually it's probably
working on that social deprivation is
the best way to change the color on the
charts
you know but I think it's also to know
from the police a bit more directly what
crimes they're recording so if you do a
vehicle stop somewhere
in one of the better suburbs for one of
a better word
um and and you check somebody's license
and then five months later you're in
another suburb doing a domestic violence
and they're probably both indicators
that come out of the deprivation chart
and so knowing where some of those
pockets are really high intensity crimes
certainly around in family crime around
homes
is something pleased to help focused on
so they can give us I mean if you go
back 10 years ago we used to get dots on
the map that showed you where all the
crime stops were but is knowing what
types of crime we're dealing with as
well as is important I see your hand at
the very back
yeah
get into it
but we intend to have a community that
has lost their faith and trust within um
police Society a good number of the
incidents that occur there go unreported
which when you're on the ground within
the community
these are very regular so unfortunately
that probably doesn't look too in favor
for us when we are
um requesting
uh support around CCTV and Bluff as well
so I'd just like to have that yeah and
as I threw the curveball to pay me
a Pioneer before a lot of crime gets
sorted out without the police and wind
off as well I know that
which can have some good things about it
and some not so good things about it
oh excuse me is it possible for Timmy to
actually sit at yeah yeah more than
happy for that to happen
so this is the last slide with the
overview
um so again I think with that quarter
row we've just heard always data is
limited and it can only give a partial
picture
um but these are some more useful pieces
of information that you might want to
consider so
um you can see there's some income
statistics
and then also benefit dependency levels
um
36 percent of young people and stuff
invercargill experience exclusion
compared to a 20 national average so
um
that statistic is one of the key drivers
for invercargill being the um pilot
location for the Vodafone foundation
work with rangatahi with young people
um however on the more positive side the
work of South alive and surveys that
they did in South invercargill showed a
much increased level of Pride after that
city a city project in the South City
um the next fact is something that's
more qualitative and it's really come
through
um a lot of the social agencies and the
meetings and work that they've had that
they feel that social excretion has
risen significantly since covert in
terms of isolated people and people
experiencing health or mental health or
domestic violence challenges within the
community
within the invercargill city we still
have high levels of volunteering
compared to the national average but
these are declining and that's an area
that that's been focused on by the
Community Trust as well as other key
stakeholders in the community in terms
of how they can support groups
Access to Health Services as we saw in
that earlier stat around deprivation
remains a significant exclusion Factor
however one of the things on the
employment side that is that may be a
positive indicator is that number of
jobs in the health sectors increased by
325 and the anecdotal feedback from the
sector does seem to be that some areas
of exclusion such as access to doctors
Etc are starting to lift a little
um
physical inactivity rates are high in
invercargill so this is a wellness
survey that's undertaken nationally
um basically a quarter report taking no
physical activity in a week so that's
something that obviously is an important
consideration for our Leisure and Rec
teams and others
we talked a bit earlier about um
qualifications levels 30 of people in
the city or in the district rather have
no qualifications at all
crime victimization levels which is a
more a lower level
statistic that would is one of the
things that forms that crime
deprivations statistic or actually level
in the city but they are rising in Bluff
so whether that is actual levels of
crime rising and Bluff timing or whether
it's for some reason higher levels of
reporting that is not clear from the
information
so um
together those statistics are really not
intended to say this is the whole
picture about our district and what's
happening but these are
from the information that is available
what we know
and there are challenges and limitations
with the data that can be used and
shared and often organizations like the
police or the Ministry of Social
Development they they don't share
information at a lower community level
because they want to maintain privacy
and they have concerns around
um around sharing data so often it is
quite difficult to find
um specific information about challenges
um really just a question about the
benefit different dependency levels am I
assuming that this excludes national
super
because often
it it yeah yeah but sometimes it gets
conflated and I want to be really clear
that people understand what the
difference is because
I think
um if we're talking about
um job Seekers or
um people in ill health or things like
that being on benefit compared one to
the other but often in my experience
they include people like me who are on
national super
um that's that's the difference and why
one set of Statistics are so low
compared to the other 2.8 percent is is
quite a variable really to 11.7 it is
it's a really high variable
um I will find the absolute specific of
what forms that definition but it is
household benefit dependency so it is
affected by the number of people that
live in a household and whether the
whole household is dependent on benefits
or only one or two members of that
household is taken into account with
that statistic thank you for that
um Rihanna
yeah I've got a lot of hints of Ellen
I was going to ask something along the
same lines actually it would be a I
think it'd be important for us to know a
lot of this Statistics here don't mean
that much to us but what would be a good
thing I think to know is how many people
do we have that are unemployed how many
people do we have on a sickness benefit
or on any benefit and it would include
super and then what is the statistic
statistic
compared to the national average of
those things
because I don't know about you guys but
I'm seeing quite a few people around
town these days who don't look well to
be fair but they're out and about
and I'm just wondering if we hire
you know because they look pretty
deprived to me too as well because these
people but I'm just wondering if we uh
where do we sit in the in the National
situation as far as those things are
concerned
um I would need to look out the
information specifically on both those
questions to tell you the actual numbers
but historically and I'm not aware of
that Trend having changed we have low
unemployment rates compared to the
national average once you factor out
seasonal variation for
um the large food processing let's get a
view of it where we are yeah we're
significantly lower in unemployment and
I'm sorry I don't know the answer to
them and how many people on sickness
benefits I can help with that so I have
asked MSD for that exact breakdown
because one of the things that we Face
recently I think Tom alluded to to this
about three months ago was that we have
uh unemployment
to 2.3 which is one of the lowest in the
country but we had 15 youth unemployment
and and to Harvard University three
times now and I've asked formerly now I
want to break down those because we've
got a used pocket there that's not being
engaged given some of these other
statistics that you've got there about
things like uh social isolation and
stuff that's a major worry going forward
so I will get that data
it gives us a bit more of a breakdown
yeah
okay and we already know that Mario
overrepresented and health outcomes as
well as the education outcomes as well
as wealthy outcomes and given that blood
pressure has a population of 42 percent
Maori yeah it's more likely we're over
represented of that but it's not
reflected in the in the starter here
when we're talking about access to
health services and things like that
uh as well as um you have 30 of people
have no qualifications in invercargill
well given our statistics around
education a tape poor attainment that'd
be interesting on what that looks like
as well
so just as a reflection of that just bit
background information
um I've spoken to both National and act
about their future aspirations around
the social uh social investment fund
that they're going to develop
and where I get a little bit stuck with
the people in Bluff is that I use the
word targeting should we target the
community for investment in some of
these key areas that will lift up those
statistics and and I get a bit of
pushback on from the committee saying we
don't want to be targeted but sometimes
you have to acknowledge that they're
overrepresented if you don't do anything
about it and they stay in there in their
pocket so I'm working away with some of
the key stakeholders on National level
to try and get some investment of that
area
uh I think these people's next
about superannuation
superannuation is not a benefit in New
Zealand it's a universal entitlement to
which we all become entitled at age 65
so it is not defined as a bin number so
I think that should be clear while it
might be interesting to have the
statistics or the number of their
resident population who are on
superannuation I think it does need to
be remembered by everybody
superannuation is not a benefit it's a
universal entitlement
bring me
look I just want to talk about the the
bit that touches on physical and
activity rates now so obviously I guess
the gist of that is
around health and and being healthy with
exercise now
it just touches on the health aspect but
I don't see anything up there that
touches on one of the critical things of
our community's health
and that is what it eats now the stats
for New Zealand is 31 percent of adults
it's over 18 are clinically obese the
definition of clinically obese is that
your weight is affecting your health so
and and if that is so you put pressure
on the health system so what I'm getting
at is what we eat now there's no
statistics on whether invercargill
people are high fast food eaters there's
no statistics that they were it's
cheaper to buy
soft drink than it is milk or quality
food quality food is so expensive it has
GST in it
um and this seems to be dodging a
critical part of
of of who we are and and and the health
of our community which really really
concerns me
um I just look at the queues with KFC I
mean it's good food and Everyone's
entitled to eat what they want and
McDonald's but but far out and in the
supermarkets you know what what is the
cheapest food
um
there doesn't seem to be I mean
obviously this goes all the way back to
Wellington and taxes on on the food that
people should be getting so
we can't change that but it'll be
interesting to know how our community
lives and is it because they are poor
you know where we we can't afford
to eat well
we need to move this discussion along so
just two more quick ones I think Tommy
hit your hand up and then Grant
yeah I don't know the size but really
but I think we just need to be careful
about statistics that were quoted I
think the broad General picture is
pretty clear sure you know areas of
degradation are particularly in the
South and probably in Bluff
um but between censuses the the data's I
must say guesstimates it's not quite a
guesstimate but it comes from all sorts
of sources and it's very very debatable
we're just we're just going through a
census at the moment I think when the
results are published will get a much
better picture in detail but I think at
the moment when you're starting and
doing it the real granularity of this
data
um I think we just need to be in mind
that the last reliable data that we had
was five years ago
um and but it doesn't change the overall
picture no no no great yeah like I I
think it's a story of productivity and
economic
um growth because all the things that
we're looking at a real of its home
ownership of its health of its ability
to buy food is linked to
how much money or households earned and
and you know so I think we've got a
decision to make are we going to be a
welfare dependent City
and expect handouts from central
government or are we going to be an
aspirational City that's going to look
after Itself by driving economic
creation and wealth creation as an
outcome of that and I think it's a
really important thing that we need to
grip up with getting a strategy for the
city in The Wider region through the
likes of Great South and those sorts of
things and then making sure we partner
really well with central government
because you know we're we're at a
precipice of either we go become social
dependent we expect someone else to pick
the tab up or we Define our own success
by finding opportunities and they are
there around their economic success
and that's a key challenge I think out
of this data
just a final Reflection from me um
when I look at the statistic like
roughly a third of our young people uh
experience exclusion well part of that
will be part of that will be covered
but part of it will be the transition to
Esports and other gaming activities that
can be exclusive in the terminology of
exclusive there they Encompass people
but they physically don't get out and
meet them
and in some places we don't have the
right activity to give them an
alternative like a pump track or
something else so Tom was quite right
statistics can be played with by any
organization government that's probably
the worst at it that they'll they'll
tell you that we've got two and a half
percent unemployment but they won't tell
you that 15 of them unemployed uh what
percentage are young people which is our
future and what you're talking about
right so that we have challenges there
we know the big picture some of this
will help steer where we need to go but
you're quite right we don't get help
bent about in the stairs because you can
play with them
Rhiannon they need to move on so the
next part of the workshop
um talks specifically about extension of
services out to some parts of the city
that don't have them
um so I'm just looking at my colleagues
um
Leslie and Russell at the back as well
sounds like passenger transports also
topic councilors would briefly like to
discuss
um but hey if we want to start with you
and the Waste Services
yeah just before Pete starts um I'll
just give an overview for those that
might be watching and you know feel free
to say
um so that people understand what we're
doing in the waste management space so
unlike other contracts that we have that
we share with uh the other councils in
the district invercargill has this sole
management of the current recycling
contract uh the southern district but
he's up to us they've got a peripheral
contract and Gore does not have a
peripheral codex so all their waste is
going to landfill and so the city
post the decision about four or five
years ago has continued to manage that
contract because it got quite dyslexible
for us and more recently we've had
papers come through from recycle South
about the issue of broken glass
in our in our system it contaminates the
paper and cardboard to the extent that
we can't on sale and there is a
significant cost of that so I guess
that's what's coming back I guess from
the history the history of it one we we
own the contract as it were and the
others buddy up to us and we're not we
don't have any mind of the state to let
go of that contract and the other issue
that we will have to face is do we
collect glass independently so it
doesn't contaminate the other products
we're one of I think three councils in
the country that doesn't have a glass
Clayton Auckland parts of Christchurch I
understand and here everywhere else has
does have a periodic pickup of glass so
it can't be going into the other thing
the other thing that it's on the list
that Rihanna has put up is also the
issue of us not checking the bins to
make sure they comply
so that's something we will need to
discuss as well and for the art react
you're looking a little bit strange at
me so that means that at the moment we
don't check the bins ahead of bond
picking them up that was on our agenda
to do that it elapsed the health and
safety issues of the race which I think
are a bit of a red hearing to be quite
honest but we need to check the bins to
make sure people are putting the right
waste into the right bin and where they
don't they get an advisory letter and
after that they get a small fine that
encourage them to do it because that
makes a huge difference once it gets
down to the recycling plant if there's
too much contamination
Peter the floor was yours
thanks Mr chip
um so I provided some very
Dialogue on the slide there but
um there are the glass contempt
contaminates fiber and currently uh
removal of fiber for us is a cost there
are six grades of fiber and there's a
potentially a possibility that it'll
become a revenue stream rather than a
cost to us
um safety we tend to the safety
reporting from our recycling people is
that cuts from glass seems to be the
biggest problem and they've got large
costs on maintenance of their Machinery
as well obviously that this thing
through it comes through to us as a
through the contracts we end up paying
for it in the long term I have some
general numbers here if you're in
interested in what it would cost to
implement a glass glass or something so
for the initial Capital costs for
distribution of bins it'll be somewhere
between 1.5 and 1.6 million
and then there'll be an ongoing annual
operation cost of somewhere between 450
and 500 000 a year
sorry could you quote that number again
apologies I never count your ongoing
operating cost as well uh around about
450 000. at this point in time to see a
pretty Glass Room
uh for for the actual collection costs
yeah
yeah you have a super bin just for glass
foreign
those figures you've just quoted does
that allow for the savings that we would
achieve in the contamination waste that
go so is that the net in result or is
that just passing out that service I'm
not taking in a into account all the
other savings that we would achieve
that's just pricing the service okay
have your price the savings would
achieved we need to work through that
details subject to uh council's
decisions on the way forward of this
so as a bit of a steer we've had a paper
from recycle South that I've forwarded
on in the last couple of days and that
suggests that the savings
from not having that the contamination
level which I understand is up around 14
15 16 and needs to be about a third of
that or even less uh it's about 15 000 a
month so that's quite substantial okay
just just to give us a bit of urgency
um
cycling came in uh to effect back in I
think 2010
and after two years uh of it wastenet
realized that it made him a mistake in
combingling glass with the recyclables
product service 2012. we knew we'd
cocked up okay it was a decision that
was made it's now 2023 and we're
starting to actually think about it so
I'm not saying waste net is a bit slower
than bloody glacial movement but things
just look you know
unfortunately sitting here as a council
has been here 12 years and hearing this
is great news but it's also extremely
frustrating that we're just
far out I mean I'm almost at the point
of oh I'll only believe it when I see it
but this is this is a start so so I've
just got to bite my tongue and we'll
just see it happen but it's been on the
radar for so long that
and I don't know why you know why it's
taking that long but I'm just saying
that waste net is probably not the right
mechanism to be doing these things yeah
Ellen I've got a series of hands
let's see what
um
I'm just clearing your costs away but
have you looked at other possibilities
of um
of collection as opposed to a household
bin like there used to be a farm member
rightly a dump station in Bond Street
where people would actually just take
the class at the moment there's no way
to take class to except put in your
rubbish so I'm just wondering is it
would it be a far far cheaper option to
have
a dump station or several dump stations
at some similar to probably the clothing
bins you see around the place in each
neighborhood or four or five around the
city spread so so that in fact the cost
of collection leaked in the glass is
you know heavily heavily reduced so
which makes them if it's not a big cost
it's more likely to happen and any more
quickly is that an option you looked at
uh we haven't looked at it but certainly
intuitively you would say that it would
be cheaper because the cost at the
moment there is nowhere to take class
two recognition it's right on the river
or or throw it in your rubbish you know
that's right no I'm just saying
you know what I mean just um these
little things do you need to be a bit of
urgency and I'm just thinking I can get
that cost much much lower much lower
um that's more likely to happen so we do
have the one option which is the recycle
station itself does have a slot for
glass and you'll have noticed last night
that the government has canceled the
recycling of cans and bottles that they
were trolling that that's been put on
the back burner
um so I guess today's discussion is not
about whether we to be fair though chair
that the recycling station that you know
is very unvisible with yeah I do
understand that profile sites you've got
to go looking for it to find I have
appraised there yeah so one of the
issues that we will face today is not
whether we have glass
and the separate bin or how often it
should be picked up and what the cost
should be it's just whether we want
staff to scope that for us and and if
you hear what rangi had to say
my viewers we definitely need to have
the latter because this is dragged on
for about a decade
yes Ria thank you Mr chair
um just a couple quick things so as
mentioned that well you mentioned that
the rubbish um is not being monitored
for what's in it at the pickup point so
there have been quite a few of the
tracks stopping and actually when the
bins go up I understand that they can
actually see through those mirrors of
these grass clippings in there they put
them down and leave it there with a no
and I've seen that happen quite a bit I
don't know if that's for every suburb
but I have seen it happen
um I've been a great believer in the
old-fashioned glass Hub collections when
I was a child even in a couple grounds
in Glengarry where we had glass
um hubs that they would come along and
pick up so I think that whilst yes um
the household collection with the bins
and the ongoing console that could be
expensive there's definitely a need for
us to do better with a glass waste so I
think the bottom questions does the
council want to consult the community on
introduction well absolutely yes
so just as a reflection about that um
certainly in my brief time in Council
we've talked about this educational role
of trying to educate people but you need
to have an enforcement arm as well if
you're going to that's true because
people just ignore and some of the stuff
that comes through to recycle stations
not a good look
um if you get it wrong then you put it
into landfill and landfills based on on
not on volume but on weight so Glass is
very heavy and it bumps your costs off
as you go so we definitely need to
tackle the glass issue I've got a whole
lot of people up Tom
oh is it me yeah
um yeah look I'm gonna swim a little bit
against the tide I think I think if you
asked the population of invercargill to
rank one to a hundred the biggest
concerns in life
then glass recycling would be somewhere
between 99 and 100.
um and I must admit that's Kingdom of
you too I like the idea of the
collection
station I know that doesn't get
everything but you know people who care
who probably would put it high in the
list of things
um would use it but when I when I when I
think about you know the cost
one and a half million
um and four hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year and when I when I think
about what alternative things we might
use that money for I think there would
be higher things in the ranking and and
without you know I mean how much would
how much would it cost us to provide a
bus service to Bluff for example you
know we've talked about that earlier and
I bet it's a lot less than this so I I
think we need to and I think we need to
think about priorities as well as just
whether this is a good idea
um a halfway housemate will be the bolt
collection station and let's think at
least about whether that's where we want
to use this money are there other things
we would want to use the money for great
yeah fully agree with that I mean it is
it will be a cost a costly excise but it
is an excise that based on a standard is
is expected elsewhere in the country
so they all have the glass it's not
every week it can be two weekly three
weekly whatever so your stock build up
it at home as well
um so we'll get the environmental
pushback on on the need to have the
glass recycled and touch away but the
issue is not the recycling of glass
because we currently do that it's what
you do with it and where you take it so
if you don't have a separate bin it goes
to landfill by way of people just
throwing it into the wrong bin and that
significantly push up pushes up your
cost around the weight Vapor because
glass is the heaviest product to be
recycling
and there's some eye-watering amounts
around the landfill at the moment that
are discouraging us from having that
weight Factor so we just need to be
mindful of that Grant
no no Peter yeah thank you
we've been encouraging the residents to
recycle for years including grass but
What proportion of the glass the three
cycle is actually used for something I
know we've got a stockpile yeah and it's
it's massive it's getting larger by the
day by the way yeah so what percentage
is actually put into use I know we were
getting it ground down and yeah I can
help you with some of that stuff to
Asphalt for foot pounds
um yeah asphalt was a bit of a Pioneer
Sky thing about having the glittery
footpath as you walk around that the
primary need at the moment is to grind
it up so we've got McGregor concreting
at Winton that does it they grind it
down so fine it's just like the sand on
the beach so it's very very fine
and this suggested users that we should
use it for our infrastructure they use
it to pack around pipes as we renew
pipes and go it's quite a good material
because it's reasonably flexible and the
water runs through it so you don't you
don't get a pipe getting too rigid so
it's not open to damage so there is some
good ongoing use for it but the key is
whether you collect it so at the moment
they try to stockpile it for roughly a
year then the machine comes along and
grinds it all up so you get about 120
their spills or whatever it is for a for
one day while they grind up so we need
to find some space in the city for us to
stockpile it so the machine can come
along once or twice a year to be able to
grind it up but it needs to be an
industrial area because of the noise
Factor at the moment if we don't do that
it'll go to Winton and we'll have the
cost of transporting it to winter but
the other issue is the glass most people
the community think glasses are
recyclable so they they put in with
cardboard and everything else and when
they do that they contamination as it
goes on truck it breaks up when it gets
the recycle savings a lot of the other
product that they have markers for
particularly around cardboard and paper
can't be used we have to then dump it
because the contamination is too high so
that's the issue we're going to resolve
trying to separate those two here
for many years
um glass was sent up north and melted
down and come back as yep so I can talk
to you about that quickly
um used to go to the family in Auckland
but the costs have got prohibited for
doing that are the recycling cost of
taking it to The Foundry organ is too
much the other option is the government
did suggest that they would trial a
return bottle and
um glass and Tin you get 10 cents or 20
cents back on the product they've
announced yesterday or the day before
they're going to back away from that at
the state so that's not an option for us
it's too prohibited because again it's
all Freight is white related if you put
a container of glass away it'll be
hugely expensive to get it open now I
have suggested to Ministry involvement
why don't they set up or help set up a
Foundry base in Christchurch to satisfy
the South Island
it goes in deaf ears unfortunately
are those returnable soft drink bottles
and beer bottles many years ago with a
lot of money they've still got old days
of small ones are worthless weapons
they're arguments sections and the kids
used to pick them up from anywhere
shorts meeting Trace meetings yeah
wherever and take them to the local
shopping okay
ABC Butlers and notipuni Avenue used to
seeing of the Court models of of Empty
Bottle beer bottles back it's Hull yeah
but then it become too expensive that
that's 40 odd years ago then they
actually after that they used to put
them in the container and crush them
here and send them up as a crushed
product but that doesn't happen any
longer well it's still weight related
that's that's a dilemma yes I've got
I've got to move this on so I'm too
quick ringy and the intrusion then
yeah that's right yeah thank you chair
Mike questions around the costings
provided by Peter and so key things are
in in your pricing the size of the bin
that you've quoted and the collection
frequency like how often is it going to
be collected and then obviously
regarding Transportation costs where
would it be taken to
invercargill or somewhere else or
whatever so what what can you answer
those three questions yeah sure so the
size of the bins on the pricing is 140
liter or 240 liter and it's recommended
the 240 liters yes for glass
um in terms of the frequency that was
from an annual pickup of uh 21 858
households per year frequency they'll be
uh uh fortnightly
fortnightly okay so 240 is the size of
our big yellow bin correct so you're
saying that did you price it out monthly
because obviously filling up one of
those big yellow bins
I mean does it because obviously the
collection is a huge cost Tom's already
raised that hey you know this is serious
money we could be doing other things
with it sure so would you have there
the 1.5 million oh um so the 1.5 million
is for the supply and distribution of
the bins okay one off costs so of course
the average so the running costs four
hundred thousand yeah if you if you have
the collection you yeah you you'd like
to have the cost so so that's a one-off
cost those bins right cool
um and Ria is the last speaker
oh sorry Trish was it Trish sorry yeah
sorry my mistake that's right
that's wrong and so for us to make a
decision about whether it's sort of a
practical thing to do in terms of
funding we really need to know if we can
what sort of savings will be made by bus
recycling happening
if it's possible yeah absolutely yep so
just just want to reflect Rihanna's
already with admire a couple times that
what we're asking for today is just a
paper on this we'll get the data back we
need and the backdrop of this is we've
currently got two layers of waste net so
those are the new need to understand
that so we have an operational level
where staff meet with the other councils
we have wastenet which is also a
governance group as well that sits above
that and and hasn't been operating for a
long period of time and so we need to
get that kick started again because
there are some important issues to be
made collectively as three councils but
on the recycling one just to be mindful
we hold the contract and we'll continue
to hold that contract
foreign
so the next topic is about curbside
collection for communities that are
currently unserved
yeah maybe I'll lead into that Rihanna
um just as a curiosity I floated in
otatara recently about shouldn't
shouldn't we or could we have pickups
because we don't have it there we pay
for it another day some do their own
Recycling and get rid of their own
rubbish but we pay for the bins so I've
got two lots of feedback it was quite
interesting
um I'm back off the notice board that we
have one was um a bit of an empathy for
the company that currently picks up that
runs around and picks up the bins would
would we as Castle would then be taking
them out of the picture that was the
first issue
um and what would the cost be for us to
do it compared to what they paid at the
moment
um so I think we get it
weekly I think we put your bins out and
it's about 180 bucks so if council did
it would it be more than that
um so there were two sets of feedback I
got so it's not a given that all these
other suburbs want to be in the network
it's a little bit like not being in the
then the story system at odatara you
have a choice on that as well
yeah Peter thanks so um if you can go to
the next slide please
we've pulled out the um number of houses
that would be service per each of the
suburbs that are not currently serviced
as we see old guitar is uh by far the
the largest if we were to introduce
um into odatara based on the number of
houses that would be a six percent
increase in extended the services
a year uh for this for the smaller
suburbs they're obviously looking at
those numbers be run up anywhere between
10 10 and 15 up to 20 20 of that cost
per suburb
so if we were to take that in in all
unserviced uh
suburbs in entirety that would be around
about 700 000 a year to extend Services
everywhere
so just as a reflection of that that
doesn't mean we pay 700 000 a year
because you're going to be mindful of
that some of those suburbs are already
paying privately and they would have to
pay through rates
which we don't pay in otatara for
example so I'm not ready for the pickup
of the rubbish so while while we've got
the 700 000 that would be offset by an
increased rate for recovery but it does
bring the question of do we leave some
of these suburbs alone and there's I
think Tom was saying before is this a
high priority for us going forward or do
we want to focus more on the glass issue
it might be the higher of the two
priorities I mean I don't have the
answer to that but
Rihanna's sitting there looking at me
and saying nothing so this I guess this
is one of the questions that we'll have
to ask staff whether we want to progress
down this line Tom
well become a resident of Wichita
um I don't think I've ever spoke to
anybody in our satara that much cares
about this issue
um
my view and again I'm only repeating
myself I think you know we we have to
make choices we don't have Limitless
funds I don't know the increase in
service 10 area is rated one in the
circle deprivation scale is something
that would be high up my list
sure
Lizzy
my question on this one would be do we
have any
resident and rate payer
um groups or Forum presentations to
council demanding that we increase the
service to the currently unserviced
areas
my reflection on that would be that no
we don't and I would probably be in the
line of saying it wouldn't be high on my
priority list either when you when you
look at the statistics and the fact that
we haven't got
I demand
from people saying it's a service they
are being deprived of in ancient Heath
if if demand was to was to happen
um we might perhaps
feel differently at that stage so
um and certainly that's my intake on
otatara I can only speak for that suburb
um people go there knowing that they
don't get rubber sewers they don't get
water supply and they have some choices
around sewerage
um some are in there and some item there
and they go there knowing that there are
issues and is that a priority
um I hear nothing from odatara which is
a big chunk of that that says that they
are suddenly screaming up for a rubbish
pickup
ringy look I I've heard what people have
said about the choice of these areas now
and appreciate that I think that the
only thing worth investigating I think
is the economy of scale that if they
were included we saw a dramatic drop in
the whole cost of per household service
you know if that did work but if it was
going to be the same status quo price
passed on then you know what I've heard
from the people here you know it's up to
each individual and it doesn't sound
like they want it but if it was going to
be a 20 percent
saving for everyone joined together then
it's worth looking at
I'd be surprised at it if it is
I think currently the biggest Hot Topic
on auditarians Minds is actually the old
golf course in the issue with the um
overgrown grass and lupans out there
compared to them having to think about
whether we want to pick up their waste
but I guess my question is how much do
these Scopes cost is there not a way
that we can do simply a poll on our
invercargill website or our invercargill
um Council page to give us a
pre-indicator as to whether or not this
is an issue for the residents in otatara
and therefore index mechanism will Clap
into place
I think what ring he touched on is an
important issue because I think what we
get by way of rating creatures probably
about similar to what the trucks what we
pay for have the trucks pick up what we
have out there is we have a choice some
people don't have bins and they deal
with their own waste and they recycle
down through the thing so they do they
have a choice around because it's deemed
to be a bit of a lifestyle somewhere but
I think if I convert it over I'd put I
currently pay about 180 a year for a
pickup
um from among the southern transports
and might be Northern transport one of
the two
um and I suspected if I went to rater to
be comparable there's no cost savings
uh yeah Evelyn
um
Mr T I think I would be more of the mind
that everybody needed to be actually
directly contact you know mailed so that
they could respond rather than something
um like a poll on their website because
not everybody accesses those things
however I think for me it would be
everybody in or nobody in rather than
pick up a any area of the city that
we'll expand to
um I think that that's
over the years what it has always been
is that
there's lifestyle decisions in this and
with lifestyle decisions comes other
consequences now it may be that people
are more of a mind that they would like
to have their collection
extended but the only way to know that
for certain would be to actually pull
everybody and then it's everybody gets
collection or we retain the status quo
rather than pick out select groups like
watatara
um about a hundred dollars to get up
Florida every single litter box in
overtime if if you wanted to prompt them
to then come back onto a website to give
you some feedback about where they want
to be included or not
look my my advice would certainly be to
consult before their services extended
but right now if we wanted to do some
pre-engagement then an informal
pre-engagement would be an option but
certainly
being rigorous and reaching everyone is
is not probably what I would advise
right up front but it's absolutely
formal consultation would need to
consult all community members affected
if there is such a consultation I think
it's essential that the people who
receive that know what the impact in
rates would be it's not a freeze service
absolutely so all long-term plan
that we consult on are audited and they
have to include cost savings cost
impacts all of that information needs to
be developed and that's why we're asking
now are you even interested in these
Services because it's a lot of work to
scope up and get it audited for
consultation so if you're if it's not a
priority then we don't need to do that
work
I'll come back that priority in a minute
um Ellen
the odotara for 40 odd years and um like
Tom I talked to a lot of people out
there because of the nature of my
businesses and I've actually and they
don't all know I'm a city council and
I've heard no one really like I think
I've ever asked me or talked to me about
getting a rubbish collection service
sure I personally pay about 600 a year
because I get a weekly pick up and um
that's just the way it is like I mean I
don't think this is really an issue that
we need to worry about at the moment I
think we should be more concerned with
the glass and the rubbish that sure that
exists now get that fixed up once that's
fixed up then maybe we look at other
issues but I think to look at the two
things at the same time is crazy at
least get the one thing sorted first
that's actually affecting what happens
now and then later which is as well so a
quick pot straw poll around the table
there's a 23 of the households number
cow or two restaurants yeah so quick
stroll stroll pole around the table does
anybody oppose what Alan just said that
there's not a priority for us at this
stage
the issue Brienne and Peter I think
we've got to do the costing um excuse me
Mr me out sure that casting has to be
done because if you're gonna
tell people you know this is what we you
don't think we actually need at yeah
because it's going to cost you you're
paying years you said 180. it's going to
cost you say 270 if we do it yeah I
think we've got to have just like we've
got the pricing on there we actually
need to know and the scale of what was
done is there that saving we have more
customers and it's cheaper
yeah
doesn't mean we're I'm not sure about
the letter I think we'd end up with more
volume that we'd have to process so
volume volume as a quantitative figure
as opposed to a
economy of scale I think
so we need more trucks to pick up if we
need to Tara for example and we'd end up
with more volume and weight and in their
recycling bar than we did there as
opposed to what they at the moment
a lot of people at a time take their
recycling into town as they come out of
town
amazing
but I don't want to make work for staff
if we're not heading down that track
yeah yeah I I agree with Evelyn uh if
it's going to be happening in under
Tower it's got to be all not just some
couldn't be look here the system we've
got at the moment is not uh to all you
pick and choose whether you want it you
couldn't have a a bond pickup system
that some people saying use two and some
are saying no to be an absolute
nightmare yeah you're right it has to be
all or nothing but like Alan I've lived
out there for 20 something years and I
don't hear grumbles from anybody I just
leave it Park it's not a problem now any
problems
come back to the live stage if we need
to yeah that's a steer For You Rihanna
oh the road ceiling
yeah welcome team if you can use a micro
you can see the microphone so yeah
just for those are listening
thanks for the opportunity this morning
um
I've brought reinforcements with me this
morning so Leslie McCoy who's my
transport asset manager has prepared
most of this but I thought I'd just set
the scene for you we have
um
a number of unsealed roads we have about
110 kilometers of unsealed roads in our
district so we've got about 600 K's of
total rating so about 18 of our city
roads uh unsealed by gravel so I guess
that's the the problem that we're
dealing with so I'll leave it to Leslie
to run through these and if it gets too
hard then um I'll run
so could I just make one reflection on
that Russell for your benefit
um we had a mayor's meeting with there
uh wakakote in Wellington a couple of
months ago
and what they flagged to us was they
don't have any money
they run short of money
and lay terms and that was driven by the
number of e-cards coming into the
country who don't contribute to road
maintenance so they don't pay any
Diesel and the campaign Road user
charges or fuel taxes so if you've got
one and every three cars coming into the
country at the moment which is one of
our pushes doesn't contribute to roads
there are some issues there for us I
guess are they the subsidized eCards
yeah I know they are yeah I do
understand all that but the thing is
it's it still cuts down the pie for some
of the areas that we we might want to
look at like we always get this thing
thrown up about the road ceiling to a
Maui for argument's sake and what's the
cost and what's what I go to eat the
ability to help us fund that and I just
see the national purchase sliding away
from us they're more in the current
floods which are another issue
altogether basically
sure thank you um so just continuing on
the conversation of one community and um
our people and the environmental aspects
of of an unsealed roads um the issues
that we seem to get from our community
is the dust the um wear on their
vehicles the speed issues and the
maintenance that we currently provide on
the level of service on those roads
um there's a few issues around funding
as marinavi just uh alluded to and that
the pot has gotten very tight
world and that they do use a cost
benefit ratio to
prioritize who gets funds when it comes
to unseal roads previously in the past
they have been a two percent ratio they
have also been up to around the four
percent ratio so you'll see on the table
later where our lands ours land in that
in that uh ratio
um is also could be other funding
mechanisms like development contribution
private funding by residents themselves
and or fully Council funded and we're
just trying to start the conversation
with you guys here about
um what would be fair and transparent
and
criteria for having the conversation
with the community not just on a course
benefit but the other issues that these
roads face so if you just throw to the
next slide though thanks and so we tried
taking the physical characteristics of
the road looking at the traffic Podium
dwellings on the number of dwellings per
kilometer the dust impact so that would
be if there's um Community Halls Etc
down the road the gradient incident and
the heavy vehicles on those roads and
then we also put another ratio on there
being the local priority of the road so
that's in relation to is there a
national park at the end of the road or
a regional park on the end of the road
and those kind of considerations there
so really I'd love some sort of a steer
from you guys looking at those
weightings whether
they are what you'd expect to see
and whether when we do continue down a
policy for sealed Road extensions
whether that's what you would be
expecting to be the ratios on those
so before we get into that discussion uh
just so we don't go on too long on this
issue
um is to consider the last debate we've
had the first part of it is do we want
to consider this in the next 12 months
um so some good examples are um you know
what happens if you go and low on Fury
Road out the back end about a time well
if you go and live there you know when
you go there you've got a gravel road
you make a choice about that then you
expect the city to seal it or do you go
to
um one of the back roads of otatara that
initially had three hours on it has now
got 15 houses on it does that change the
ratio of pothole on the gravel road and
should it be sealed even though it's a
short road so there are a lot of debates
in that issue putting aside the whole
issue of funding so I don't want to get
drawn into individual roads we'll be
here all day if we do that just is this
something that we want to have on the
front end of our long-term plan to be
considering we do have greater
priorities elsewhere Evelyn
and the issue of dust I think
um for those people whose water comes
off the roof I think would be slightly
more significant than nine percent so I
think it depends not just on
whether the road is sealed but what
other services they have because if
they're dependent on water
from the roof for their property also
some roads because of the Constitution
of the surrounding soils are actually
um you know the Sandy more Sandy soils
are more prone to
fly up shall we say and settle on the on
their roof so I would think if we're
looking at health benefits that's one of
the things that I would be taking into
consideration right
um two things uh the first thing is
development contributions now I've
raised this with Russell a few times
about how roads have become you know
they might have the three houses on it
and now have 20. because someone's done
the development and Russell's told me
this Council doesn't have development uh
chose not to have development
contributions now
when when did we do that and can we
change it I mean obviously if we made
that decision at some stage and it's
obviously Darren might know as we call
my time or
goes back and somebody during your first
term and yes we can review it at any
stage correct because obviously it does
put a pressure on the road and the
second one is about the dust and that's
a valid point by Evelyn now I would have
thought that in there just a district
plan or and building consents and stuff
you could not build a house at a certain
distance from a gravel road you know for
that very reason because that dust is
imminent you know we do have dry seasons
and I thought that would have been and
collect the water off your roof and I
would have thought that would have been
part of the deal but obviously it's not
yeah so
um that's just sort of Common Sense
thing to me
but that development contributions thing
I think is critical and if you somehow
end up putting a dairy farm at the end
of a road you've got a milk tanker it
has two trips a day and I remember stats
at a local government conference that
said
the movement of one Dairy tanker is
equivalent to 11 000 car movements on
effect on the road
so yeah there we go so I'll just I'll
just remind you that because you
probably don't know and Russell's got a
bit of a smirk on his face because he's
feeling comfortable now because he knows
that we've got another Workshop coming
on this exact issue of development
contributions
so today today's not quite the place for
him
Mr chair I guess the reserve the
development contributions you need to
remember that all the properties that
have been built okay retrospectively
deal with those great so a lot of the
properties a lot of the roads that we
get a lot of feedback from are already
subdivided and developed so our ability
to retrospectively deal with those is
quite difficult and the second part of
that is if you collect
a quarter of the amount to do the work
there's a growing expectation as you
collect it that you're going to do
something and sometimes you've got to
buy in to actually get the rest of it so
you might have 10 of the properties
developed and they might pressure or
have an agreement that you have to do
the road early so you've got some real
issues that you want to carefully
contemplate on the way through that
process all right so so and the last
question and this is for Russell why
does Waka katahi and it's not their
fault their only funding is through fuel
exercise and the excise from mileage on
diesel that is there and a couple other
wee things that is their only income not
one cent of tax dollar goes into our
roads and we are probably geographically
a country that needs roads we've got
mountains we've got everything and
coastlines
I can help with that before you suck
some mirror at near Russell and we had a
we had a presentation at local
government Museum on this specific issue
and Chris Bishop was there the transport
uh spokesperson for National and he's
his acknowledgment was that we will
probably under a right-wing government
move away from the current tax system
which is fuel based and
diesel kilometers to a flat rate for all
vehicles regards to whether you're an
e-vehicle or not and you purchase those
um those kilometers depending on the
rating of your vehicle so obviously a
milk truck would pay a downside more
than a wee car price but they're gonna
even the playing field out but then
still wouldn't be enough funding well
the the idea of that was it was to
secure enough funding for so that it
does need tax dollars okay so it'll be a
little bit different system
so perhaps we might just run through the
rest of the slides sorry and then we'll
hit some so I guess what we've just
highlighted here is we've run
I guess the criteria over the roads we
have and we've just brought it back as a
sum as a summary
um in the middle there there's the BCA
which is a benefit cost ratio so it's
actually showing you
what your benefits are against your
costs
also looked as the ranking using those
other weightings just to see whether we
get similar numbers coming out of it
because in reality the problem isn't um
the first problem you will face is how
much do you want to spend and then the
second most and the more difficult
question is where are you going to spend
it will be the challenge and what is and
that's really what the the benefit of
having the weightings there is actually
gives you a I guess a a Good Steer about
where you should start to focus on and
on why so we've just included I guess
um the roads where we get most of the um
feedback from ratepayers about uh
concerns in their areas
so Russell just to give you some
feedback on uh
I've driven every day sometimes twice a
day of them some of those roads as you
know there's a rural delivery contractor
and I can talk to Staunton Ray which is
a good example
um it does chill out in a wet weather
but the cost of nearly a million dollars
to to repair that piece of road for the
very small number of houses that are
down there I mean yes you couldn't
justify in the short term
um so there's always pressure on
everybody wants to have seal Road right
up the front door
the relays on Earth we just don't have
the dollars for it unless it suddenly
becomes a much higher priority than
other things we've discussed today
here pania I have to say the actual
Green Point Road and the um Maui Road
have been on the radar for over 20 years
now yeah
so I just have to say it's like
but I guess I guess what Russell might
be alluding to is
um if it's being on the right eye
forever and I die it doesn't mean that
Yanks you do it it might be that the
conditions that would justify you doing
are not there the traffic loading is not
there so Mr chair I guess that the
fundamental question from our asset
management process is to give us a
reasonably Good Steer whether or not we
should be contemplating working through
that and including it in our plans
because to be fair in the past we have
and as the budget gets tight that's
always been the thing that's finished
but it's just to give us a good
direction
so in a report last week on
infrastructure
there was a um
uh State there that said we had seven
reported potholes an eroding Network so
I took it upon myself to do some
statistics and drove between Bay Road
and bainfield Road and found four
potholes just a net six in a road
so when we're talking about expanding
our routing Network I think what we
should do is focus on our existing
Network and lifting the quality of that
which isn't great in a lot of areas and
reference downside shell Gladstone there
that that's
someone biking along there if they
weren't Observer would fall off because
of that routing piece there in some of
the aspects of Herbert Street just the
name too so if you expand that across
your existing Network I think we've got
a lot more issues around the quality of
our existing routing Network as opposed
to expansion and more cost yeah good my
view
about the milk tanker it's actually 1100
movements not 11 000. so one to Eleven
Hundred and it contributes economic
value to the country oh absolutely
[Laughter]
significant amount of money that we
could use somewhere else so is there a
lot of feedback or was it some or
well I guess truth what we're looking
for today is just to give staff a steer
on whether we want to go down this track
excuse upon and whether it's something
that we want them to do more work on or
not and I think Grant race is an
interesting issue about you need to
maintain what you've got at the moment
and not spread your dollars too thin
because you'll end up with a bigger
Network there's poorly um more poorly
maintain
I think it's worth noting that one of
the reasons we've put this forward for
discussion is at the time of the last
long-term plan there was a community
submission specifically on a Maui Road
um and they they ask that it be
considered and then the council at the
time of the last long-term plan said we
will consider it not we will do it but
we will consider this issue as part of
the next long-term plan and that's one
one of the reasons we're having this
conversation now
Leslie
thanks Mia Clarke
um I actually think that one of the
significant points here as to why we
would leave the Sun for at least
consideration is that on our own ICC
criteria before at the top of the what
is now disappeared from the screen
actually score above the 25 percent
so we've got you know 31 27 27 and 26. I
think at least those four should stay in
for a consideration phase because they
score so high on our own criteria and
while I certainly agree that this
maintenance we can do on the rest of our
radio network
um I'm
I think there is some justification for
saying if they're scoring that high on
our own criteria they should at least
stay there for consideration
again all I'd reflect on that is the the
keywords that she said which is for
consideration because the value of those
four upgrades are more than dealing with
glass
ing a high criteria appreciate that
I missed so many times
yeah I mean I'm not absolutely clear the
question we've been asked to do but I
think in the jet the general question
about Road selling I mean the whole
history invercargill for 150 years it's
a progressive ceiling Awards as I said
it's been modernized so I I certainly
don't think we should ever see that we
would not seal any more roads to me
that's just a modernization of City I
mean it's about like you know
undergrounding electricity lines or
something it's something you do as the
when you can afford it as you progress
so I mean I I think we should be
interested in looking at you know high
priority cases that come to us
um I do support or development
contributions as a concept
um and again electricity network does
the same thing
um so I I I don't think we should say no
I mean I think individual cases should
be judged in an individual we're against
the general bike drop that the city has
always progressively sealed its roads as
it's modernized and enlarged
as Russell quite rightly said though
some of those contentious streets we've
got and if you include a Marion to that
as well getting contributions will be uh
non-existent because the existing brake
pads are already there
and in the case of a Maui it's not the
residents so much it's the traffic that
goes past the residence that seems to be
the issue for them
no other discussion all right
Rihanna
you're free
well maybe not we want to talk about
passenger transport which has already
come up yes so
um we've brought forward in those
earlier conversations councilors the
ones that we were already aware of that
were either coming up through the
management teams or from the community
so
are there other
we don't need to get into a big like we
don't need to get into a lot of detail
now but we would just like an indication
from you if there are other services
that are not available in the whole of
the city that you would really like
considered as part of this long-term
plan that just gives the asset and
activity managers chance to think about
scoping those up because it's a lengthy
process we've already talked about
passenger transport
um are there any other services that you
just want to flag at this point
I'll certainly flame it for you Russell
which is the issue of Transporter Bluff
and that's not a boat catcher for me but
it just seems
um that we haven't got the mix right I
regularly watch the buses around town
lucky of one or two people on each bus
as they're going out of the city
um surely we must have some flexibility
to
to reschedule some of those ins and outs
and and maybe have a bus system that
goes too bluffing back in the morning
and same thing in the evening that can't
be that big a cost compared to what we
run out some of their suburbs at the
moment so just something to be from my
hand to be thinking about whether so it
may not necessarily be a new cost or not
a significant new content might just be
hey we need we can't have this regular
bus system that goes out with one or two
people on it as opposed to Bluff that
constantly cries out for a bus system
that comes into town
I think as you've seen that mere
um I'm you know looking at any table
nearly everybody's nodding as you're
saying it so I think it would be a high
priority for the council sure
if we do that I'd like to consider
education needs for black students as
well it's no high school there but
obviously not just for the students we
probably want you know they would go
earlier than perhaps other people might
but definitely put that as a
consideration into the mix please so
thank you for that that's my ignorance
Russell so I don't know whether it's
possible for somebody that might need to
come into a doctor's appointment in the
morning can get on the school bus as
well
thank you to be fair that you have been
at least two attempts in my time as a
counselor to set up a bus service in
Black they have both fallen over I think
if we are going to
put consideration into how we might
extend a public transport services to
Bluff we need to research those Services
the usage of those Services the costs of
those Services the timing of the
transport that those Services involved
and why they did not succeed I I can
share a light on one of yes I
yeah I don't know that we want to go
into it deeply today I just think the
world has to be made certainly it would
be necessary as part of looking at it to
investigate I can see I can see Russell
nodding as we speak
I'm certainly aware of those two trials
yeah
exactly what Lizzy was just talking
about there and the um information that
would have been collected at the time
the last blast service to invercargill
um
um shot down
um I guess the other question there is
you know if if we're looking at the
bluff to invercargill route and all of
those assets to make sure that it is
successful what is the pull for atatara
residence in invercargill and back to
ardachara
there as well yeah I can probably help
with that
um that has been looked at before by
Council
uh being a resident of otar I'm aware of
that but again
um getting from outer tire to the city
if especially if you're in the Aged care
area is a half price taxi fare because
Council actually subsidizes taxis for
that age bracket don't broadcast it too
loudly but you can get in about
relatively achievement getting from
Bluff to city is a different program
altogether and and my from I guess my
argument about it you know how many
people get on the bus every day where
you don't run a big bus
you run a much smaller 10-seater van
from Bluff in and out just so that you
get and if you get one person going in
and out so bad some of the buses we have
running around the city at the moment
are bigger and they only have one
personal great
and the cost of the alternative for the
city if you didn't get on that bus is
much cheaper than if you have to run the
bluff so that creates some sort of
social isolation in my mind
I started a tower
of course
correct
um
yeah it's a social good that we do yeah
springy
um just to check it out there we I mean
obviously this Russell the regional
councils are charged Nationwide for
looking after transporter secretary
correct we currently have a delegation
from environment South and to operate
but other Regional councils around New
Zealand actually do it themselves
correct yeah so I just wondered is that
something we need to look at so this is
something we need to do or is that where
we can pass back to the Regional Council
we currently have a delegation from them
that actually outlines how we would
deliver it for Southland
so we have a responsibility to look at
all the services and the underlying
agreement says that we're the costs lie
that that Council would pay for them so
for instance if someone wanted something
from
an example Riverton gautamaterra for
instance in the gore District Council
because the situation is is that you you
need a specific service that meets the
criteria from wakatahi to gain a subsidy
so council could engage and decide they
want to run a bus service and subsidize
it directly
and that may well be what you're
suggesting in Bluff which will then mean
that you would then decide to set your
own fears and run your service as a an
exempt service which means you can do
that on a scheduled basis but it does
mean that you will actually understand
what the true operating costs are rather
than and not be subsidized but other
than the fare box that's offered by the
people using it so you can set your
fears and pay the cost
I can't tell you Russell that from zone
five and six which is the South Island
Zone to local government New Zealand
this issue of isolated communities and
bus services is really high up on the on
the agenda
damn just following on from from rangi's
question were you asking though we
sought the delegation from the Regional
Council can we hand it back
Mr chair the answer is yes but there are
some terms where you have to give notice
and I guess I mean if I look at realton
as a good example they ran a bus service
at one stage into town
that fell over and then the Lego Rooney
set one up themselves and got funding
for it and I understand that's now
fallen over true lack of patronage so
it's a little bit like how long's a
piece of string and how much will it be
used but it's certainly worth
investigating I think
yes yeah
I think it's not binary around lack of
access equals a bus service sure and you
know I think there's a much greater
importance of us understanding what the
actual need is and why that is right
because in summer it links to how much
responsibility is on individuals if you
live in Bluff you know you're sort of in
a community that perhaps doesn't have
all those services so there's going to
be a need for you to have to get to
yourself to some of those services or
employment right that's a choice that
people make but equally that we summon
the community that needs support and I
think we've got a really diagnose how
they would access that support and then
what it looks like to get the outcome
and it may not be a bus service it may
be some other form of Transport that's
intermittent and might resemble a lot of
characteristics of public transport but
it might not be a bus sure
leave that with you Russell
and the last agenda item is CCTV
he wants to speak
to it I was just checking whether
Jonathan wanted to come and
this is really just a relatively brief
update and I guess the first slide
really just talks a little bit about
what we've um
brought to Council in in the past and
and I think the major one of the major
things from our stakeholder Workshop was
really that the um
the working group there was looking for
a safer City
and CCTV will contribute CCTV won't stop
crime
I guess that's one of the key things
that we need to continue to and it may
well be that in a wider context for a
safer city that um Council may wish over
time to look at some of the other
factors that will actually add to the
safety of the city CCTV is one of the
elements we can do it's a big slide
Rihanna oh just a comment of that
certainly that the feedback I've had and
I know rang he's done a lot of work in
this area is it doesn't stop crime but
it can be a deterrent if you know that
you're being watched
so the balance between that and the
right of people to not be watched is one
of the issues that we deal on yeah but
also I challenge that because if you
talk through to the um police you know
what what it enables them to do is it
shortens up their investigative time so
it creates more police heirs to the
employees in a proactive way which will
reduce crime so I would challenge the
assumption that it won't stop crime it
won't stop crime absolutely for sure but
it will significantly reduce crime and
that is the findings from across
Christchurch with their significant CCTV
Network it speeds up the ability for the
police to get
that people that are responsible for
crime in front of our justice system and
therefore releases more police areas to
be able to do other stuff so it's a key
to it the feedback we've got the police
was quite clear so he said if you have a
major burglary going on in the CBD you
can run all over town looking for the
vendor if you've got license plate
recognition you can track them as quick
as a flash yeah yeah and then police
hours are available for other stuff
it certainly does a system in solving
crime so I guess this next slide is
really just about talking about where we
are and we're currently
um writing a paper to come to the
infrastructure services in April which
outlines this in more detail our
consultant Scott Bain who
um who may you may have met has been
doing a lot of user needs with the wider
community so they've he's talked
extensively to the Mary wardens and the
community Patrol
the major stakeholders the police in
detail
um so and he's developed a preliminary
Network
we are suggesting that we have a staged
approach um at the moment as you'll see
in further pages that we are suggesting
that potentially around 60 cameras be
placed around the city so some of those
are number plate recognition some of
them are just some of them are actual
image but that sort of has a a budget
yeah outcome of about 375 000 and
currently available budget is about 200
000 so there is a gap in there
and The Wider stakeholder group was
presented I guess some of his outcomes
and he was really suggesting that the I
guess the wider context of all of the
cameras should they be all implemented
is around a million dollars total so
that's sort of the order of number to
actually do it in a number of regions in
the latest lines we talk about those
regions and regions are really just the
areas everyone wants to pop the next
slide on hopefully
um
that's the city center one that just
shows the locations and if you just go
to the next slide which is probably the
more important one and it's not
necessarily about it's about what they
control and how they will support the
police so the police are looking at lots
of control ins and outs and they
recognize that
if you know whether the cars that are
stolen are then you can understand
there's something not going to go on
that's appropriate so they look at a
whole lot of that type technology so
so really it's that's the sort of area
where the wider scale project is looking
for so put the Reser paper come into the
next report sure one quick question for
you Russell um in the early stages when
we had the discussion with the police
they were very keen on plate recognition
in and out of arterial rage so I could
see the people coming in from Gore from
Riverton from Bluff whatever
but there was an additional cost to that
technology and I put it to them at their
stage should they contribute and I
didn't get a response from that so is
that still a possibility that they may
contribute so what we understand from
the police is that the police don't own
cameras anywhere in the country and then
and their underlying business direction
is that they don't own vehicles and they
don't own cameras
um so that's a thing for the community
to deliver
um so the short answer is from the
police now
it was interesting because when we
talked to Scott who's a specialist at
um consultant rang he's been engaging
with as well
he said there's a difference between
cameras and plate recognition options as
well
don't need to have plate recognition
everywhere but you need cameras
everywhere but if you need that extra
layer so the police can track why are we
wearing the cost for that so
I'm not saying we shouldn't but I'm just
saying it is there an option there for
the plate recognition part of the
technology
oh cancel skip I think you're sorry
Nigel I thank you um just as you're
aware Council saber and I are on that
working group and we've attended the
meetings add some subsequent discussions
with Scott in with
excuse me
um the key issue around the project
itself is obviously the safest city and
selling that to our our communities and
selling it to New Zealand in the sense
of we're creating we've created a new
CBD but obviously having a safer city is
a really good selling point for mums
dads caregivers and our children and our
future so we were all very committed the
whole working group to the work that's
been done very clearly and I know
councilor potting has done a lot of
previous work on this back in fact back
dating eight years when that first
figure was muted at 200k
so we do the simple sums going forward I
think we need 350 370 for phase one
uh which would just secure the inner
city and we'd create that safer City
perception doesn't stop at all but I
think from Leslie in my perspectives the
phasing in of the of over time phase
over perhaps a three year period
um maybe the answer
but certainly the other issue that
cancer pottinger is very aware of is the
sense of the locality and also
um the maintenance and so on so about
having locals being involved in or
councilor pottinger would be really
important if we can I think that's a
really key going forward the police are
very much on board
um and it does give us a massive
opportunity so we would be supporting
this from uh Council of serpent myself
back to the full Council that we should
be pressing a button on this as quickly
as we can
certainly for phase one is where we're
sitting at the moment
thank you
the last speaker
cheers Mr Mayor like one of that just to
give you a sort of understanding of
where the costs lie is that if you took
about 400 000 for a system
um
up to half of that is in providing the
network it sits on so it's not just cut
uh camera Hardware it's got to go
through a network join in to get back so
that's that's another
specialized part of this whole system
and so that every time you expand you've
got to expand the network and the great
thing is everything is getting cheaper
so
there's not many things you can say that
about
and better and better but just just on
the Privacy thing the thing that you
you that trips up the Privacy is when
you start using uh the facial
recognition
features that these cameras some of the
cameras have and and but you don't you
don't have to you don't use those you
just use the other ones but
um this will be great this would be like
glass collection
well it's only eight years as opposed to
team for the class
Lucy the last speaker
I'm going to say
a comprehensive report in April I think
once councilors have that in front of
them they will see exactly the thinking
the amount of consultation that's gone
on the consideration that's gone into
the privacy issues and the network
issues and that will be the time to
really drill down to what um
councilor Scout has said and I agree
with the the need for the CBD obviously
to be the first phase but there are a
lot of following phases that will that
will deliver us an ideal solution for
other parts of the invercargill city
which are going to be really important
and that I think I just have to
emphasize the consultation with the
stakeholders like the police
the community Patrol the Maori wardens
Etc has been comprehensive and I think
in the report that will be collected
okay thank you for that
oh they're very very last speak of it I
I was just going to admit the point that
you know if you were a criminal and you
intended to do a ram read or something
of the sort and you you were aware that
the Central City had all of those
cameras
and then you'd be more likely gotten do
it in Windsor and doing so safe so I'm
not sure that
um you know when we think about
CC's TV we should I I love you we should
actually think about the um you know
those areas too you know those areas who
get significant amount of shops
um you know that's what I would do yeah
close it now because I've got I've got
some pressure on how to get this
finished uh I just will make one quick
reflection I mean CCTV is not about crop
always about crime prevention it's about
the perception that you feel safe
somewhere I think Leslie touched on it
before
all right we're going to ask residents
wait three years to feel really safe
well yeah it doesn't add up again that
will come with the paper that's coming
in April yeah so I'd like to see in the
paper recommendation of what and it may
only be cost about what's the
opportunity to go
big yeah oh I'm quite up for that I
think we we should look at that but
there is a cost Factor yeah
yeah there is yeah
it is yeah it was always on the cards it
was never enough concerned yeah okay
that's the workshop closed thank you for
your attendance today thank you for
those that have listened online we'll go
off